لامين يامال
مراهق مغربي الاصل يلقب بميسي الجديد في
برشلونه ليس من السهل ان يصبح لاعب حديث
العالم في 15 من عمره خصوصا وان ذلك الامر
حدث منذ سنوات مع ليونيل ميسي في بدايته
لامينيا مال شارك مع الفريق الاول
لبرشلونه لاول مره في مباراه رسميه والتي
جمعت بين البارسا وريال بيتيس لحساب
الجوله الثانيه والثلاثين من الليغا تلك
المشاركه جعلت يامال اصغر لاعب يشارك مع
برشلونه في الليغا وخامس اصغر لاعب يخوض
مباراه في تاريخ الدوري الاسباني بعمر 15
عاما و290 يوما المدير الفني لبرشلونه
تشافي هيرنانديز وصفه باللعب الاستثنائي
واكد انه يشبه ليونيل ميسي وانسوفاتي في
موهبتهما الفطريه كما انه يسبق عمره بكثير
ويتمتع بقدرات فنيه رفيعه
[موسيقى]
المراهق الاسباني ولد في اسبلوغاس
ديوبريجات وهي بلده صغيره باقليم كتالونيا
لام الغنيه واب مغربي ويعد احد اهم مواهب
اكاديميه لمسيه في السنوات الاخيره لا
يسمح برشلونه للاعبي الاكاديميه الساكنين
في المدينه ان يعيشوا فيلامسيه ولكن تم
استثناء لامين خوفا عليه بسبب انفصال
والديه
ما يميزه هو ان لديه القدره على اللعب في
اكثر من مركز حيث انه يمتلك قدما يسرى
ساحره ويمتاز بالمراوغه والصناعه والتسجيل
ويستطيع اللعب في العمق كمهاجم وهمي وصانع
العاب او على احد الجانبين كجناح ايمن
وايسر لذلك شبهه كثيرون بالاسطوره ليونيل
ميسي
[موسيقى]
يا مال يستعد لطرق ابواب الاحتراف بعد ان
غير وكيل اعماله ليصبح خورخي منديز
البرتغالي الشهير الذي صنع رحله كريستيانو
رونالدو الاسطوريه هذه الخطوه من المفترض
ان تؤتي ثمارها خاصه وان اللاعب يعاني من
مشاكل انضباطيه تسببت في اكثر من عقوبه
تاديبيه في برشلونه وحرمانه من المشاركه
مع منتخب اسبانيا للشباب المواسم الخمسه
التي قضاها في اكاديميه الامسيه جعلت تشاب
هيرنانديز يراهن عليه ويبدي اعجابه
بموهبته اكثر من مره ويصر على استدعائه
للفريق الاول قبل اتمامه لعامه السادس عشر
وبعد العديد من الحصص التدريبيه مع الفريق
الاول يقرر اخيرا الدفع به في مباراه
رسميه بمنافسات الليبيا
الخطوه المنتظره هي توقيع اول عقد احترافي
له مع برشلونه لكن على النادي انتظار بلوغ
الفتى الموهوب عمر 16 عاما وهو ما سيتحقق
بنهايه الموسم الحالي
[موسيقى]